get ready to hop on call maybe I'll
stream tonight Anna oh and the stream
sniping me what is this
look at this
it's me
oh she was just watching my stream on
mute
hi Anna
[Music]
we're on a delay so this is weird it's a
weird way to communicate but I guess we
can talk through this way too yeah we'll
have to like wait five seconds after we
talk to each other
yeah let's hop into a call that sounds
like a great idea all right
all right best duck chess players in the
whole world and that is very very very
exciting uh to to be able to learn from
the best
yeah I'm excited for this
um I I don't know if there's an official
duck Master title yet but
um I've been trying to grind my way like
up the leaderboards
um there there's some like really
serious duck chess players that I
haven't passed yet that I'm striving
striving to get into like the second or
first place but it's it takes a lot of a
lot of time and effort to to raise the
duck rating
I don't know actually that there were
like Duck standings what is your Like
official like Duck standing in the world
do you know so if you go to like the
there's a um the leaders tab on the
chess.com variants page and then
under duck chest Blitz like there's
different duck ratings for like dark
chess Blitz and duck chess rapid most
people play Blitz I'm currently number
four on the leaderboard but the the true
duck Master is Dragon B70 who's over 100
points higher than the second spot uh
with a duck rating of 2212. so Sunday
medieval will have a match
so the world map the world like past
duck chess player in the world is 2200
in Duck chess basically that that's the
highest rating yeah although we haven't
played any games yet so uh I'm curious
how I would fare against him but uh it's
such a new variant like it was only
added to chess.com within the last few
weeks that um
like there's no one that has
long-term experience maybe apart from
like the founder of duck chess because
this very was actually invented in in
2016.
um and only recently made its way to uh
be playable online
but you're one of the people that has
really popularized stock chess right so
I mean it's a lot thanks to you that
Doug chess has become as big of a thing
as it has been so that is super awesome
oh yeah continue the collapse to Eric
clap Eric has done a big job here well
it's really cool it's really cool I mean
I just like streamed it as like kind of
an experimental thing a few weeks ago
seeing that was a newly added variant
and there was already kind of this meme
in my chat with with ducks because a few
years ago I got chased by a goose that I
thought was maybe a duck but a guy
together that's a whole different story
but uh the fact that there's a duck
chest variant it was uh it was very
intriguing for me and I I did not expect
people to be so fascinated by this game
but it's such a great game because it is
such a simple rule change that just
creates a whole different world of
possibilities so would you want to like
hop into uh playing a game and then
talking through it I I have a few
different ideas is like we could we
could play against each other and just
keep it educational we could maybe team
up against someone
um of course in like a casual game but
uh yeah I'm flexible I think that sounds
good I think that we could just like hop
into we can start with one game and then
we can talk through the game and we can
do a couple like educational games and
then maybe I mean I know I'm gonna get
crushed but it would be really fun to
play one game against you even though I
I'm 100 sure I'll get crushed but it
would be really fun do you want to just
start with that and then that can be
like a jumping off point for kind of
like some lessons and patterns and
everything sure sure you can teach me
everything that I did wrong I think that
sounds good yeah foreign I'll challenge
you to five plus four
that's kind of the second
um time control
yeah sounds good oh there we have it
all right I think I made it rated so if
you win you'll you'll Farm me for a lot
of reading points let's go
start with like oh no wait I wasn't
supposed to put the doctor I meant to
put the duck on B2 right yeah that was a
duck slip no this is actually a duck
slip I just pressed somewhere okay but
um is it good to start with moves like
this yeah
um I I've seen a lot of players do this
and it's kind of one of the metas of
duck chess I'm just kind of doing the
same thing and now we get to a situation
very early where the duck is going to
have to stay on this long diagonal
to kind of save both of our Bishops
yeah and early on like I think it's it's
important to like still stay with basic
chess principles of like develop your
Knights and Bishops trying to fight for
space although we're playing kind of a
more modern setup
what do you think of it like an H4 H5
setup
oh
um that would make that would make sense
against a Pawn on G6 for sure
uh the drawback of playing H4 H5 is
there's cases where I would take the H
Pawn and then block your Rook on the H
file and then ensure you can't take back
so yeah I just wanted that I would like
destroy your king a bit
yeah yeah there's um I think there's
different patterns when it comes to
attacking this game that even if you
ruin my King's High Pawn structure it's
not so unsafe for me because the like
with addition of the duck it's such a
good Defender that my king can be wide
open and it can be still very hard to
attack
so you're never like scared of so much
about your king like even in open
positions
for the most case yeah like compared to
normal chess King safety is much less of
a concern in this game
yeah that I think is like once you
understand that you you can be a little
bit more wild with how you I like that
how you expose your king
thinking that the duck is a night that
does happen to you too that happens to
me like the first day I played duck
chess because it has a similar shape as
a knight but um yeah after playing this
enough I've realized it's its own
creature and it's
um
yeah it's kind of like distinguishing
between and like a deer and an elk
eventually you'll learn the difference
yeah no I I think I will I'm just uh I'm
just very new to it still but
um I I like it I really do okay so I'm
trying to put the duck on F6 that your
knight cannot uh go out but now you're
gonna Castle queenside I suppose I have
a different idea I'm actually like
you've given me an opportunity in this
position and oh oh no it's a common
situation in Duck shasper upon attacks
at night
and now I can place a duck to take away
your retreating swear
and now you have to figure out what to
do with your knight
okay so what
it what if
because you really want to exchange your
Bishop for my knight right
that's uh yeah that's one of my goals I
think I can do this maybe are more
powerful in this game
Ah that's interesting so
yeah you prevent Bishop takes E5
I will take and
I will play this
okay so I will
do the same thing I'll just stop you
from taking it
now it looks like your Bishop defends
epon but uh whenever there's like a
distant defense like this I'm happy to
take and then block the defense
but what if
wait
wait I feel like
foreign
I feel like there is something here
you're you're looking for like the
skewer tactics right
yes I am yeah the the problem
is wherever you eventually place a duck
I can always put the duck back on C3
so I know you can never like fully
unleash the diagonal
um
it's very sad there's sometimes
exceptions to this if you like if you
make some additional threats
okay I'll just do this that's
interesting yeah because now I have to
ensure I don't lose myself
but uh yeah I'm trying to attack a lot
of things at the same time okay which is
a good strategy generally
that's good
wait I have an idea okay
what happens
and then the duck
and then
what happens if I do this
ooh okay so I'll show you what happens
free Bishops
you made a triple attacker but it's
with the duck it's so easy to like get
out of trouble
all the things of like Queen takes
bishop and then the duck has to move and
then I was calculating everything if I
didn't have my Bishop on B7 that would
have been a brilliant idea because then
you would essentially force with my
queen or King I appreciate the
positivity but uh yeah but this is how
you learn is uh yeah you you log into
these failed tactics and
um
hopefully you'll you'll avoid them for
next time
wait I have a plan
okay
I'll go here
and
here
interesting
okay okay okay
what if I go now
Queen check and then here
that's actually really interesting I was
just thinking about that
um
this is the plan with Queen G4 yeah
now now it's actually getting crazy
because my my king my Bishop my rook and
my queen are all in danger
but I can I can deal with it I think I
can take your bishop and then block the
check with the duck
[Music]
and I guess I can
I not go
check and then here
oh
wow
so now you're attacking you're basically
attacking my king but my Rook is also in
danger
so I have a couple options here I could
I could move my king and then play duck
B7
there's also a really funny move which
I'm kind of tempted to play
what's the funny move
uh wait for it wait for it I just have
to calculate
I think it worked I think it's okay
actually to save my king and Rook
so one thing in this game is you can
Castle into check like there's actually
no official like concept of check in
this game
but if you leave your king attacked you
have to usually use the duck to block
the attack
okay I see what you yeah I saved my king
and my Rook
yeah yeah that was actually really nice
and this looks terrifying for me but the
duck is going to keep me safe hopefully
that is actually very pretty
so what if I go
thank you Nathan thank you
um
what if I go
Queen check and duck B8
yeah that's one way of uh forcing my
king to move
okay I'll see what happens okay
Queen check
and then duck the eight yeah you're
gonna win some pawns here
um
try and cut my losses
make sure you can take on D5
this is kind of sad because I'm about to
uncastle
okay I mean it doesn't really matter
where I go
[Music]
they're just gonna run and I'll just
pick up all your pawns our pawns
important in this game at all oh yeah
pawns are still like long term
if you can win enough pawns you can um
they can be very useful in that end game
if you have like two past pawns the duck
can only stop one of them
okay but here we're gonna see another uh
very common type of quaktic is I take
the rook and I block your own Rook
oh no not the case again yeah you you
were too busy taking my pawns no I was
so excited about the Pawns
wait but what if
Queen check and stuck here that's a fair
move yeah I have to be careful
I have to continually save my queen
being attacked by the road I keep
forgetting
Queen Chuck and duck here
wow that's actually fascinating because
you're attacking my Rook you're attack
you're basically pressuring my king and
my queen
um I have a really funny response as to
play this and this
I'm playing this move I defend my queen
wow
yeah because I can't really move
anywhere
wait that is like the prettiest move
I've seen thank you
now there's a whole different aspect of
geometry in this game
yeah I'm gonna get flagged this is very
intense wow that is actually so pretty I
would never have found that move I feel
like
yeah when you play this game enough
you'll start to find all the cool Tech
or all the cool clocktics
uh okay let's just do this I'll just
stop you from moving around I'm gonna
have to go very fast now
hmm
I feel like Rook suck in this game
yeah Rooks are um very easily blocked by
the duck
my time
okay no mercy
Aquatics continue
[Music]
Oh no you're a queen
know how blender really badly no okay
okay wait
no okay no other sign I'll resign
okay if you want to play on it sometimes
interesting to see how the game can
finish
but I know I know it's a pretty brutal
position here
okay we can play on a little bit just so
you can show me just to try and show the
final duck meat
kind of like me too
because yeah checkmates work a little
bit differently in this game
oh no what do we do okay here we go
okay
and one thing I'm actually like I'm
still not that great at is finishing off
a game with like such a huge material
advantage
it's not so intuitive
no no I feel it's really difficult
nice I was the only only way to survive
yeah that's what I was thinking
so I guess I'll have to try to get
stalinated
yeah it's very difficult to get
stalemate in this game because
um
you you can usually move your king into
check
how do I how do I smother meat
oh let's play this and then
foreign
yeah the knights are too strong in this
game you're just gonna go Queen H2 now
right we need to yeah yeah this is a
common mating idea with a knife and then
I'll just
you can you can take my king area that's
a satisfaction
yeah all right good point seven uh oh
thanks for the reading yeah
less than a point of reading okay so
what was uh what what was what were my
biggest mistakes
yeah I think
um
this moment on move nine
when you played
D4
and Doc F6
once once you allowed me to play E4 this
this is kind of the turning point
okay
um I was able to win material like I won
at least a pawn and
um
yeah it's
like and this is a common sort of
opening trap is when the pawn attacks
tonight you really have to make sure
that your Knight's not getting like
stranded or you have to go to a square
where you just lose material
um it was still interesting like you you
try to conjure up these tactics of like
attacking along the long diagonal and
trying to swipe my king but uh yeah
unfortunately for you it didn't quite
work out so uh so smoothly
it never worked out at all
very sad so instead of on move nine
instead of D4
and Doc F6
an interesting option would be D4 and
duck E4
preventing me from playing Pawn E4
and this is actually like I've seen this
um in a bunch of my own games is like
when you go for a pawn break you just
prevent your opponent's Pawn from
advancing and you only give them option
of taking or
if I don't take then you're able to take
on E5 next move
yeah so
that's very nice I think this would be a
bit
a bit more balanced yeah
I think that I A lot of times like I
just basically put the ducks like on F6
or next to the king because I know that
I want to stop the development but sure
I think I forgot about everything else I
want to do as well in the game
so yeah
um there's some people that are asking
me how would you rank the piece value in
Duck chess like how much is each piece
worth that's a great question yeah and
it's like I don't know
um I haven't played this enough but
I I can say for sure Knights are of
course better than Bishops because
they're less obstructed by the duck and
we saw in this game like Bishops can
very easily be
just completely dead if I keep like
along the long diagonal it's usually a
good Bishop but if I keep putting the
duck on C3 it's kind of like a dead
piece and knights aren't restricted in
the same way
um yeah
so
but the other thing is I've realized
that in a lot of openings it can be easy
to trade
Bishop for Knights and this is maybe
like a a positional idea to keep in mind
um I'm not sure
how you could have achieved it
[Music]
um
if we go back like in the
so actually I I made a small positional
mistake on move five if you go after
uh Knight bd2 and duck F6 in our game
yeah what I should have done is played
Bishop takes F3
oh I think this is just a like a simple
good decision
because long term
uh
trading Bishop for Knight is is gonna be
very good for the side that keeps the
two knights
yeah
makes sense and
his Rooks
yeah I I think Knights are more powerful
than Rooks
so if the situation ever arises where
you can play Rook takes Knight and quote
unquote sacked Exchange
that's
actually probably a good thing in Duck
chess
yeah because Rooks are kind of similar
to Bishops where imagine you have a rook
uh on an open file
if you just put this the duck on the
Square in front of the Rook then the
open file is blocked
yeah like you were talking about this H4
idea
um to like try and open each file but
duck on H2 would uh just prevent the the
power of the Rook
yeah the Rooks are never powerful okay
that makes sense yeah okay interesting
all right I feel like I've learned
something here do you want to go for one
more game yeah let's do it okay let's do
this game number two
all right let's see if there's any
Improvement here it was crazy how you
found like this really beautiful tactics
before
okay yeah I'm not gonna hold back but
hopefully I'll it'll still be
instructive
you're not gonna hold back I like that
you're going for this um similar opening
which I can't stop Bishop G7 so
I think I'll just double fan Kettle my
Bishops
although now that you've told me you
want to double think hello your Bishops
why they do that no I think you meant to
play lucky six right
no why am I telling him this is really
telling a duck Master what I'm gonna do
so okay I think it's a very important
part of the scheme not to get too upset
that the duck is blocking your plan
that's always going to be the case where
the duck's gonna get in the way and
sometimes you just need to create
multiple at least in the opening you
have to create multiple Avenues of
development
so
yeah that's a fine move and you're
allowing for Knight E7 or Knight F6
oh why am I not stopping you though I
just realized yeah
you put the duck back on uh C6 there
I guess you're guaranteeing Knight C6
but I'm not sure if that's the movie you
want to play
I just realized but I'm not doing
anything just off of you I'm just
thinking of my own pieces okay B6 I'll
stop your Bishop now
your stream quacks me up
okay I'm stopping your Bishop
well I'll stop your Bishop again
come on Eric don't go duck piece of it
oh no okay I'll go ducky detail okay so
what I did was I I gave my Bishop two
directions to develop like G2 or
um on this longer diagonal so
G3 looks a little bit weakening but I
think it was it was worth it just to
develop my Bishop
you kind of did the same thing there
okay
I should have castled instead of going
Bishop D7
um yeah casting maybe would have been
nice to because now I'm gonna
continually put the duck on that page
[Music]
that's right after you make them
yeah I don't think like
um
I don't think it was a huge mistake
though it's fine if your kings in the
center like your King's still super safe
that's true maybe my king can stay in
the center yeah like I think castling is
a little bit overrated in this game like
a lot of people Castle but
um
not sure how necessary it is
because usually in chess like you Castle
to get your king saved but your king is
going to be safe regardless with the
presence of the duck
yeah the duck is a very strong piece
five is an interesting move
oh oops I have to make a move when my
mom says that something is interesting
she means that it's terrible it's the
same thing for you like
um well F5 is interesting in the sense
where it could be terrible but it could
also be brilliant it's some somewhere in
between I'll take that
I'll take that awesome
um
[Music]
okay so what if I do what you told me to
do what if I do this and then duck here
oh preventing D5 now it's getting really
messy
ton of tension here
okay so in normal chess
there's a concept of like
of attackers and Defenders right so
there's two Defenders
are you on E5 and two attackers for me
on E5
oh you're just gonna touch us I can
block one of your Defenders
yeah I just realized that six
okay I just realized like F6 so how do
we do this this
okay but maybe oh you'll always be able
to go dark F6 right
okay so I guess I'll take your
and
yeah you're just gonna go duck F6
anyways it doesn't really matter where
yeah once I have the duck on the Square
I'm like guaranteed to access that
square with a duck
like a long-term
Okay so
this
is
what if I try to read
what if I just try to like make my
Bishop make my Bishop good again
do something like this
interesting
now you're pressuring my Bishop on e4
okay we'll uh I'll trade a little bit
okay so you're just gonna okay
all right so I'm gonna do the same thing
I'll just go here and I'll try to block
you with everything just try to make it
messy
I think you're handling this model like
you you did lose a pawn but it's really
not the end of the world for you and you
have everything defended now
I feel like in Duck just losing upon
it's like really not as bad as a normal
chess
yeah yeah the like even like being up a
piece in Duck chess it's um
much less of an of an advantage like
I've uh
realize it's much easier to fight back
with a duck
when do you think we'll have duck
engines Eric
I'm hoping never I feel like engines
would just ruin this game
yeah fair enough fair enough I mean it
would be interesting though to like see
how an engine would play this
um it will probably happen at some point
someone's gonna make an engine and we'll
have to adjust to it but that's
wonderful yeah it's one of the things
that has drawn me to this game is
there's no
no way to like computer cheat yet so
yeah hoping it stays that way for at
least a little bit longer
for sure now we gotta enjoy the the
weeks or however long it is uh before an
engine comes out with this yeah that's
true yeah there's probably someone
working on an engine at this already in
the world yeah I think so
it's
develop
avoid the queen avoid the queen trade
avoiding Bishop takes Knights
I really want to go Bishop takes Knight
I really really want to do it
um
so
this
look okay you know what I feel like I
gotta move my
I feel like I need to get my queen out
of here
[Music]
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna try to
pressure you a little bit
yeah I'm trying to like make sense of
like it's it's getting messy already
yeah I don't really know what's
happening Eric if I'm gonna be
completely honest
I mean I don't fully know what's
happening too I'm gonna go for
maybe a slightly speculative sacrifice
oh oh my Pawn
a true oh no my Pawn moment
but how does this sacrifice work here so
what if I just go here
mm-hmm
let's play this and
I've already figured this out and it
feels like you know what you're doing
oh no
It's tricky because you're attacking my
knight with your Bishop so
I think your queen might be trapped
trap my queen
no but what if I just
oh
oh
oh no wait
[Music]
no there has to be something
you would think there's something here
yeah
because after well I can that's probably
what I have to do but I mean like takes
and then the queen takes and then I mean
like yeah I'm not getting it back
I probably have to take it though
so I mean this is the best move I see to
be honest I will have to sacrifice my
cream for the night and then I'll
have to go somewhere but I'm not sure
where I'm gonna go but okay I'll just do
something like this you'll have to take
it and then you'll just
block your Bishop I I think that was a
reasonable Choice um at least you're
getting some material for it
and uh
foreign
I'm not sure how great this is for me
actually like even though I just want a
queen
you're pretty much guaranteed to win my
night next move
unless I can somehow save it
though you said that you should
explain
why those if it's on Exchange
for nights you're doing a great job of
holding on to both of your nights so
I've been trying
to get rid of your night so far
okay so I'll just
I'll just do this
yeah at least at least now you're a
night class that is always something
so I think what I'll do is that I'll
castle and
yeah this is actually a fascinating
material imbalance because it's uh
it's Queen for two nights although
thanks for the Rook
no mercy
this is so good I just saw how my chat
started saying oh no and I was like
where is that oh no like what's
happening and then I and then I realized
that the oh no was the rock oh no I've
realized this is more prevalent than
duck chess is like it's so easy to
overlook like easy like like simple
chest tactics it's not even a duck
tactic
duck was not involved my time
that's another concern
now you're almost trapping my queen
oh no I'm trying
was this all planned
that's insane
yeah
wait no no I'm my queen my Queen's
attack I can I can save it with a duck
I was looking for Queen moves there
okay don't hurt me
oh no
oh no
thank you chip for the ones oh I
blundered
ah It Ain't Easy when it's hard
I've under the low time no mercy here
yeah this is it's crazy when you have
little time like you just get so
stressed it's hard
yeah yeah everything just disappeared
oh that was so so good though for such a
long time okay okay
I feel I feel very motivated now for the
next one
you have potential yeah
do you actually think so
take my record as long as you don't hang
like your Rooks and keep giving me free
material
oh that's free Queen oh
just as I say that let's go
okay it's time for some endgame
technique
it's actually one thing like I haven't
had so much experience in end games yet
so I don't know
I assume winning pawns is a good start
try to block you
okay that was a very annoying meal
actually
that was an extremely long movie I'll
have to try this maybe
[Music]
I don't know what I'm doing I'm trying
to somehow dying yourself still mates
yeah I'm trying to self-sell me but
oh
I should have played ducky shades
okay
I don't think how do I sell stalemate
I'm so confused on how to self-sellmate
all right all right all right all right
all right
so it's very hard to self-stalemate
because
like for example towards the final
position you
King G1 and King G2 are always legal
moves for you like you could put your
King next to my king yeah your King has
like no safe squares
so how would you celebrate like would
you actually have to be surrounded by a
box of Pawns
basically yes yeah like you if you
imagine
um
I think the simplest example
I'm I'm trying to imagine
how that would even work
oh man
there's some like
imagine
um
can you see my circles if you close out
of like the white one
you can see my circles right yeah so
imagine it's an empty board white has
pawns on
each 7 and G7 and the King on h8
and that's all white has
and then let's say the point moves and
puts a duck on G8
then white then that's an example of
stalemate because the pawns are going
this way the king can't move the duck
box upon from promoting that would be an
example of the stalemates
but the point would have to kind of
willingly still make white with the
stuff
Troll game or something right
okay okay I see I see
um wait who's saying this you two stop
playing duck cha someone said in chat
okay
um all right well should we go for okay
one more I I really feel like I'm
getting there I feel like I'm improving
for every game that we're playing with
each other so yeah you're getting better
yeah a lot a lot of this is just getting
experience it's kind of like
um
what's a good analogy it's kind of like
driving a car
like the way that you become comfortable
you have to go on the road maybe
experience a few crashes but
experience of your crushes maybe that
wasn't the best analogy but it's a much
safer way of uh kind of learning the
ropes Eric I don't know how to drive I
don't have a driver's license okay maybe
that wasn't the best analogy then no I'm
scared now I don't have a couple crashes
before I learn how to feel safe
yeah I guess maybe like riding a bike
like you just need to
ride a bike either oh no okay
well it's um it's like learning anything
in life because you have to uh you just
have to start you'll you'll Maybe
face some challenges along the way but
it's like
people
smiling face with hearts
okay I'll keep my my plans going my
theoretical plans here okay
okay
oh
I did get anywhere by public transport
[Music]
um
so here
oh you're just straight up going another
way oh you're gonna go Knight G4 Maybe
Knight G4 and then Bishop F2 and then
duck F1 duck meets
oh no my duck their deal all the ways to
stop that with the duck I probably
should just have you scared me that was
a terrible place to put my dog I could
have stopped your attack your castles
but I got so scared of the night G4 that
was so stupid yeah there's a concept in
Duck chess basically
basically like bluffing
like I'm I'm trying to scare you with
one idea so I can go for a completely
different idea
okay well I will have
I will have a good idea too so this hey
Eric do you see my Bishop on on Beach
Hill
I do I'm not too scared yet though
places
okay
I'm trying I'm trying to use my
my pawns pawns are meant to be pushed
wow
well you're also going super aggressive
so I am I had to at this point
[Music]
oh no that I'd drop my
okay wait that's not trapped it's not
trapped you do have a move here yeah
there is a move to I think save
the situation
I'll try to take yours
sometimes when you're trapped the best
approaches to counter attack
I think it's working out for you okay
well we'll have some funny trade
as long as I don't lose my Bishop
this and
[Music]
oh just something here
are you still not scared of my Bishop on
B2
not really
I'm really trying except now I'm kind of
scared but for other reasons
oh yes wait
I just hungry yeah
oh that is unfortunate
it's like even though I've been playing
this game for two weeks it's it's still
so easy to make these uh sort of
mistakes
yeah no for sure for sure come back here
you still have the knights
so it's still a long game to go
foreign
I tried making a move but it didn't go
through
oh I had that bug before I swallow but I
had to refresh yeah
oh there you go now I got it yeah there
it is I'm still refreshing so hopefully
I didn't break the server of my
blundering my queen
you know what would be cool if they
created the Rosen duck chess opening
like you could get your own chest
opening in Duck chess uh later I'll have
to show you there there is an opening
trap I discovered that I've I've been
beating a lot of people with it's like a
five move opening trap where you you
basically duck me in five moves a lot of
people I want to see that
and this
hmm
I'm gonna try to duck make you
oops
oh you allowed me to go
dark mating on G7 but you're just gonna
take my queen I just realized
I'm not falling so easy for that Eric
that was good try though Queen G7 would
be checking in normal chest but
yeah good job and being aware of the
danger
yeah
okay so if I can't wait but what if
what if I went
Bishop take something here
wow wow you're you're reaching high
level clocktics here
thanks Eric that means a lot coming from
you
really
I'm just getting crushed here
oh
if I beat you in one of these games I'm
gonna self Acclaim myself a duck Master
because I beat a duck master
uh that's only fair I guess
okay
[Music]
um
okay so I guess the most important thing
is just to take your night so
um
okay so taking the night and
where do we go with the duck
go there
okay let's go here
another great move
[ __ ] G7
is to stop you from going dutch G7
yourself
oh
oh okay you just moved there I'm down
I'm down a queen and a knight oh no
and turns me down
oh wait you're so what happens if I
okay you know what I want to do
I just want to take your your Knights I
don't care you can take my Rook
uh oh
um
okay so we'll just go for this
I'm kind of scared about your the open
files in front of my king but
better be scared
you're mine
um
so
Queen here and
I'll probably move the duck back
you're now going to use all the quaktics
that you know
that's my intention yeah this
to stop the plungering today fight back
here
now the question is will I be able to
win it though
because it's not easy even if even if
we're up a lot of material
not easy
this
I don't want to put some
this kind of want to put some intense
music
okay no wait no that took me out of my
concentration
um
that was a really nice move actually
thank you
thank you
a little worried I'll do this
hmm
I wanted to put sometimes music on but I
couldn't handle it it became too tense
oh no wait I have I my thing froze
[Music]
did you make a mail I did make a move
am I gonna be saved by the duck server
guys
[Music]
oh I feel bad
no I feel really bad you were just
crushing me that game
Oh What a Sad finish I would have given
you more time but I don't think there's
a way to give you more time
I was gonna win that I was gonna win
though but it's so sad why did I crash I
don't get it
I don't get it the game is gone now for
me too
yeah I can't see it can you can you see
my arrows
nope I mean I completely I completely
lost that game
it's like you were playing so well you
broke the servers
oh that's frustrating
that's a bit relieving for me I mean you
you were finding all the clocktics
uh
like winning my queen and then the night
I can't believe that that was like it
was like I'm never gonna get such a
winning position against you again yeah
that was like a serious wake-up call for
me
wait that was wait so what's I I don't
understand okay wait okay can we do one
last Duck game I need to get some sort
of okay this time really no mercy
yeah okay
okay there we go all right one more okay
this is the final one I will no mercy
this game Eric no mercy no mercy for me
either no no the best test the best duck
chest that there is out here is what
we're gonna play now releasing all my
secret duck strategy
yeah
I actually
no not intentionally okay let me try and
confuse you a little bit
oh no
that actually it's a bit confusing but I
don't think it's that can maybe it is
what
is it aquatic
it's a uh it's a small opening trick
okay let's just do this okay I I
completely forgot you had Knight takes
H3 there
oh
I think we're both showing a lot of
Mercy to each other
a free version I've listened to your
word and I trusted you Eric that was a
pure Bluff
because I was so sure that you knew
exactly what was going on but no well
the takeaway lesson is never trust your
opponent
I don't care about that wreck anymore
I can't believe I got this Bamboozled I
can't believe I forgot about Knight
takes H3 I mean I've I've done this in
similar positions where the knights
already develops
I know it's my turn yourself
I know
okay this
all right uh at least I'll get a night I
suppose something
okay let's just do this
and like this try to get our pieces out
now I'm realizing the like winning a
rook in this game it's not a huge
Advantage like Rockstar is so inactive
for most of the game
I'm gonna try to trap you there
okay I'll try and shot you here
hi
I have to do this again
[Music]
oh you saw what I wanted to do
ah Queen H5 no Queen F3 oh oh that was
clever actually
I wanted to go queen of three I'm I I
missed the previous nail
Okay so
this
okay
is the way it is
so maybe we'll just have to enjoy the
pawn
let's enjoy the pond
I can't believe it actually like this is
actually insane I never thought that
psychology worked this way
like it's actually crazy yeah the the
duck can like very easily cause
hallucinations
[Music]
this
okay
and now you're getting out
not only going out of the traveling your
night
tired of you trapping
I can't the world does not want me to
win today
all things for the duck
okay
I got duck trapped
very duck trapped
I wish I could do two moves with my
normal pieces
I wish I could trade one of the duck
moves yeah yeah that's a different
variance maybe we'll have to combine
these variants
well
all right let's try to let's try
something
foreign
I wanted to take your Rook but uh
[Music]
subtle for that my Rook was hanging yeah
okay
thanks for telling me that my work was
hanging at least
that was good I forgot about that one
I could have taken it previously but
then you would have won my Bishop so
it was better trade just to win the
night
let's do this okay I really wish the
duck was a night
shish kebab
oh no my queen okay this is a terrible
game no this game no this game never
happened okay
doing one final game
I know very
Primus well okay good luck no mercy for
real this time no mercy for real this
time there's no mercy okay we gotta
concentrate on cuddling on the king's
side either
oh
Sicilian wow
what are you looking at
oh wait what
I thought you accepted my challenge how
did I start a new game
oh no
can I sign up two games
please do I I'm playing someone rated 2
000. I don't know how that happened
I'm playing it you're playing one of the
best duck chess players in the world
about that
I'm offering a draw here
I don't want you to lose your heart
during rating that's true
I mean if you if you want to observe Me
Maybe you can have like an educational
type thing where I can talk through the
moves
um sure
let's see where where can I find the
game here
uh
uh you go ahead and you can concentrate
in your game and I'll figure it out Eric
don't worry
you do your thing you you win you beat
this 2000 guy and get your hard-earned
rating I'll figure it out
um
that's I'll mute myself for a moment
okay I actually just agreed to a draw so
I lost two rating points for that but uh
okay maybe I'll play that that person
later
okay uh let me actually send
yeah I have to make sure I don't like
challenge a random person but challenge
there we go there we have it sweet okay
nice okay so
no
no best game ever okay good luck good
luck
foreign
muted herself so I'm I'm muted myself
too on the call
and now this is actually really serious
wow
okay I'm hitting the pawn
uh now I'm going for some
some more aggressive open positions play
maybe this move
I'm blocking
the bishop the Knight the queen
E2 is a very pleasant home for the duck
it's kind of like a duck nest
do ducks build nests
we probably do right like they're bird
creatures
should I play Bishop H3 just to troll
only if it works
I don't think it quite works
immediately
I like this position though
[Music]
um
let's keep developing
and this and this
amused
amused
wait it just said amused
that's the wow Emoji though
welcome back TW
foreign
yeah this is uh the the wow emoji
I would have thought it would say wow
rather than amused
okay so I'm waiting for her to play C4
and then I'm going to try and get this
smothered duck meat
she might play as some g-pawn move
oh there's a funny line I'm gonna play
this and then duck G2
it's very possible she'll be losing in
one move
so I'm trying to uh induce Bishop E2
oh is she gonna do it
oh no mercy smother duckmates let's go
oh man look at her expression
oh it's too much fun
uh she fell for uh a funny line
smother checkmate
yeah usually the duck is a good defender
of the king but it's also a good smother
of the king
my original intention was to like wait
until C4 was played and then smothered
duck mate with Knight D3 ducky 2.
but this is an alternative smothered
duck mate
are we gonna do one more game
up
Eric I have
made it yeah
this is a learning experience
welcome to the smothered duck meat
I don't like this place I don't want to
be welcome here I never want to be back
in the smaller duck place
but this is the type of thing like it
happens to you once and then hopefully
you'll like you you won't have it happen
to you again
um this is actually similar to the one
of the opening traps I was going to show
you where okay there's a sequence like
after
I think after five moves that leads to a
similar type of pattern
okay well you can go ahead and show it
to me so you can show it yeah yeah I'll
tell you the moves so if you just go
back to the starting position
[Music]
um and this is a line that you would
play as black so if you can flip the
board
uh you'll look from Black's perspective
yeah
and so many people start with opening
e4.e6
.2 yeah
oh more people do E4 ducky six
I I've seen this um at least this is the
my usual go-to opening is white
so okay if you can play that on the
board
you might have to go back one more move
oh fair enough and then black will play
Knight C6
and then duck D3
okay
uh and then Knight F3 usually ducky E6
and now this is where you you kind of
begin the the trapping sequence you play
D5
and duck D3
and at first it looks like it plungers a
pawn right because white can take
and play duck D7 blocking the queen from
taking the pawn
oh take and ducky yeah
and then this is where black plays
Knight B4 and duck D3
so trying to win back upon
night before inducted
so there's no Bishop C4
yeah their light basically has an option
a couple options to try and defend
between
duck chess though
so what move would you play here as
white
um
maybe C4 keep it all protected yeah C4
looks very natural right
and then where'd you put where would you
put the duck
T4
I mean ducky two it's obviously not
working
so maybe I'll just go to D7
yeah so I've I've had this position a
handful of times or something very
similar
and now it's black to move and win you
put
will you put the duck on each Hill
yeah
um that's part of the move oh this is 93
ducky two which is a very similar
pattern to what you just walked into
this is a smothered duck me it's true
after just four moves yeah that's
actually really nice so what is C3
better
but it's actually really interesting
what you had said because
um after Pawn C4 if you put that back on
your board
yeah so Knight B4 upon C4
um if White's gonna play Pawn C4 the
best Square for the duck
is E2
you had initially said like obviously
that's not where the duck should be
because it looks like Knight T3 is going
to be some other duck mates but the
reason for white putting the dog on E2
is to guarantee the duck will have to be
moved away and then King E2 can be
played oh oh true true yeah
so
let me see if I can put it up let's see
something so C4 ducky 2 is is probably
the best move for white
I don't know how to like do C4 oh there
we go I can just do like this and you
move and now if I play Knight T3
I would have to move the duck away from
E2 thus losing my knight
oh exactly
wow and I literally said that that's a
terrible move
so it's like something funny these ideas
and duck chats are very counterintuitive
where it looks like you trap your own
pieces
but
in trapping your own pieces you're
actually guaranteeing that your pieces
will have more freedom once the duck
moves after your opponent's turn and
this is a really important concept to
understand so C4 is probably the best
move if you put the duck on E2
okay
that is really cool it's evolving duck
Theory I've like I haven't analyzed this
so deeply but this is one of the cool
openings that I've been kind of looking
into and trapping people with
the rose and trap the rose and duck chop
or the bong Cloud duck rather than King
U2 it's ducky too
oh you've already thought about a name
for it I love that
pong duck wait I love that there's
something so cool
yeah you can really do a lot of play
with the names with this yeah
I love that thank you so much for
showing that to me and to everyone else
that is really cool everyone in my
community will take notes and and play
this gnome games yeah and hopefully
raise their own duck ratings
yeah yeah I will stop being 1400 duck
noobs like like I am right now it takes
practice but I think hopefully you've uh
you've acquired a lot of experience
through these games and you learned some
lessons the hard way but uh I I hope to
to see you keep improving a duck chess
and hopefully
work your way towards duck mastery